Nếu thông thông của quen là Vô Lô Đi Mia trên lần Skey cho biết, Mỹ vỡ quen là thông nhất về các bảo đảm anh ninh.
Sau cuộc gặp với tổng thông mình đoen đoen trâm tại Bằng Florida.
Thế thông thông trên lần Skey, Hà Bây giờ đã đường những tiến chiến đáng kể hóa khóa bên gồm,
Hà Mí điểm đã đoen đoen thông nhất khoảng chiếm với phần chăm,
còn các bảo đảm anh ninh về mặt quân sự đã đạt đồng thận hoàn toàn.
Ông cũng cho biết một kế hoạch kinh tế nhằm phục vỡ quen là sau xung đô,
đang ở dài đoạn hoàn thiện của quân.
Bây phía Mỹ, tổng thông đô đoen trâm đánh xa của gặp với tổng thông của quen là mang lại cái quả tích cử.
Tuy nhiên, đón thường nhận,
bánh đe lánh thổ hiện vẫn chưa được xa quyết và tổng thịt liên gián.
Tổng thông trâm cũng chưa rằng châu Âu,
dây đông phải châu quan trọng trong cầu chúc ăn đình đường ai của quen là trong khi Mỹ sẽ có tụi hỗ trợ ở mức cần thiết.
Sau cuộc gặp, lánh đảo Mỹ với quen là châu đổi với nhiều nhà lánh đạo chỗ,
một vòng đàn phản mở giọng với sự tham gia của Mỹ, Uquena và cơ đổi tác chỗ ông,
dự kiến giễn gia trong thời gian tự.